if there is one food that i could eat
every single day
every single meal for the rest of my
life it is pasta
i love pasta
it's like a blanket around you and
eventually a bump in your stomach
there's only one pasta i hate out there
it's papridella i hate it i just can't i
won't
and then i saw our next guest on tiktok
and i knew that she was my kind of girl
she's practically royalty oh yeah that's
why i'm wearing a crown too
instead of just looking totally insane
there's a reason for this
okay take a look at her just
gorgeous soft pasta shells are rich with
flavor
just like you are ingredients i made a
sauce with onions tomatoes and olive oil
and then prepare the stuffing with equal
parts of ricotta mozzarella
once it's beautiful cover it in tomato
sauce
add some extra mozzarella and sprinkle
parmigiano like fairy dust
oh i am in love with you and i am so
excited you are here
nadia katarina also known as the pasta
queen hello
hi drew i love you thank you so much for
having me i'm so honored
now as an italian woman a
goddess i might add yes i put the crown
on but i always
named different pastas to my daughters
when they were babies i would sit them
in their high chairs and go
reggaetoni
[Music]
oh my god uh fellini
is that okay that i do that totally you
can do anything you love
pesto oh yeah that's i do that too
we would literally watch sesame street
and then i would talk about
arbiata
anyway okay good i'm glad i'm not like a
horrible stereotype
you're not alone and i do that too oh
good okay
it's this familiar lovely thing i do
with my daughters
i still do it they're older now so
they're more mortified now
people think that you're playing a
character
like the way i'm embellishing for my
girls
but this is really you isn't it i just
love
pasta i was born and raised in rome
and into a pasta family my great great
grandparents in the 1800s
started a pasta factory i mean i
remember as early as five years old
making gnocchi with my non-nagarina
so for me this is home and uh this year
through my daughter i found tik tok
which i thought was just like a dancing
app
and then all of a sudden i'm like people
are cooking on this app so i thought
i want to bring my family's tradition to
social media
and it was incredible everything just
started going viral
well will you quickly teach me here
today right now how to make a pasta
let's get going come on what are we
making today
yeah so the first thing we're gonna do
is add a pot
of water boiling and we add a generous
amount of salt
gonna make it like the ocean super salty
then we put our spaghetti in
so the sauce is so quick and delicious
it literally takes a few minutes to make
so by the time spaghetti are done
the sauce will be done and that's it so
let's go over to the sauce
we drizzle some olive oil in and then
we're going to put
the minced garlic inside and
sizzle it okay so we want to get
it all right okay so one thing that is
important is to
go on to the next step fast and we just
slice the butter
so that we put it right in we don't want
the garlic to brown
at all well so far this looks amazing
now we're going to zest the whole lemon
in zesting the lemon i'm not sexy in the
kitchen nadia i am not sexy
oh you're beautiful drew you're
beautiful
all right lemon juice in lemon juice in
yes good now you add the heavy cream
heavy cream
oh god i know a pinch of salt don't
forget
pinch of salt uh yeah
so it looks so amazing that's all it
needs before you turn off the flame
now if i see it like separating a little
bit that doesn't mean it's curdling
right it's okay
no so there's a little trick with the
pasta water
because of the starch if you put the
pasta water in
it will just glue everything together i
have
a sort of religious thing with pasta
water
which is if you don't keep your pasta
water and add it to your pasta
you are just a sinner is that too too
far
you shouldn't be cooking you shouldn't
be cooking if you don't use pasta water
good i feel the same way good so now the
sauce
is pretty much done you leave it for a
couple of minutes
and then we add the spaghetti
okay so wait until you see the
surprising and gorgeous way that nadia
plates the pasta
let's finish up nadia teach me
everything
good so let's put the spaghetti in the
pot
and mix them together adding a little
bit
of pasta water so i'm adding my pasta
in and then i'm ladling a little bit of
pasta water in there
yeah very important as i said the
starchy glue
found in the pasta water makes it all
come together
oh my god i am in love
now nadia mix them a little bit yeah how
do i make that nice
roundy bird's nest you have a serving
fork
and a little so we're going to plate
this pasta with style
we're going to take a really generous
amount of
pasta you're going to pull it all the
way up so that this stretches
and then you're going to twirl it around
the ladle
just like this see this is a revelation
i have never thought to do this in a
ladle
yeah anybody can do it from home then
you go in the center
of the dish and then you slide off the
ladle at the bottom
and you just gently
move your fork away right
all right nadia
thanks to you i finally have the perfect
pasta bird's nest
all right and then we're ready to serve
will you do a pasta beauty shot with me
just gorgeous nadia will you teach me
how to do your hair flip
oh yeah let's do it okay
ow nadia do you have the number of a
chiropractor nadia thank you so much for
coming on our show and gracing us with
your beautiful presents
and for anyone watching please go to
thedrewbearmoreshaw.com
for even more fun more knowledge of
nadia
and how to get a hold of her immediately
by watching all of her videos